So here's another game tree. We have, again, two
players, a and b, and a gets to make
a choice, first, to go left or right. And
b will find herself in a situation, perhaps, where
she gets to choose to go left or right
as well. I've drawn these little square boxes, though,
to represent chance. So what this means is that
if a goes left, you end up in a chance
box where you flip a coin and 50% of the time you end up over here, and 50% of
the time you end up over here. Along a similar
vein, if a goes right and then b goes left,
then you end up in another chance node, and 80%
of the time you end up here, and 20% of
the time you end up here. Alternatively, if b goes
right, you always end up here. Does that make sense?
>> I think so. Uh-huh.
>> So what we've done is we've gone from
a two player zero-sum deterministic game of perfect information
to a two player zero-sum non-deterministic game of
perfect information. Okay, so we've relaxed, we gone at
least one level up in complexity. Okay, so do
you understand this tree? Do you understand this setup?
>> Yeah, I think so. I mean here
the stochasticness is happening essentially at the leaves.
>> What does that mean?
>> That there's no choices to make for either player after this
randomness happens. But is that. That's not what you mean in general, right?
>> No, that's right. There could be,
after here, you end up in a different state
where you can then make more choices. But because
I don't have enough room, maybe because I want to
make it simple, it just sort of ends after that.
>> Okay.
>> But yes, this tree could keep going
on and there could be choice, random, choices chance
nodes happening everywhere. There could have been a
chance node that happened at the very beginning, even.
>> I feel like I could work out the value of this game.
>> Oh, well, how would you go about working out the value of the game?
>> I would
probably have it as a quiz.
>> Okay, but what would the quiz look like?
>> It would say, what's the value of this game?
>> Okay. Do you think that just having that be the quiz is the best
way for someone to learn or do you think maybe it can be done in stages?
>> Oh, I don't know. Do you have other questions that you want to ask?
>> Well, you know, how would you go about
determining the value of the game? I think the first
thing that you would do, at least if you were
patterning after what we just did, is you would try
to write down a matrix.
>> Sure.
>> So, I'm going to write down a matrix. So
that our students will get a chance to, to work out
what that matrix looks like and then from there figure
out the value of the game. Are you okay with that?
>> Sure.
>> Okay. So if we were going to do
that of course. The first thing we'd have to
do is we'd have to figure out, figure out
what the strategies are. So. What are a's strategies.
>> I would have called them left and right but it, but they're not labeled.
>> Yeah well let's
do that we can call them left and right. A can
go left or A can go right. What about B's strategies?
>> B can go left or right.
>> And B can go left or right.